[Music]
good morning John it's Monday May 21st
and I've got all kinds of news first
Katherine is at work which is weird
because she hasn't been work in a long
time and I'm all alone in the house all
day second you've been married for an
entire year there will be more on that
tomorrow also I recently made a video
for eco geek and which I discussed this
silly NASA project that was like a
flapping bird plane I thought it was
kind of silly so I made a kind of silly
video very exciting the video and story
got picked up on Digg and then Gizmodo
picked it up and then I started reading
the comments and then I realized that
everybody was being really mean to me
excerpt from the comments interesting
ten of ten informative four of ten
annoying eleven of ten dear
eco geek you are not safe rank please
stop trying to be I want those bird
things to be fitted with razor sharp
talons sent to that geeks house and make
him pay for that voiceover someone
please do him the favor of just killing
him they're so mean what are they also
bean I mean what did I ever do to them
put some razor-sharp talons on show you
not safe Frank kind of Talon you to
death I have some chocolate or something
I mean congratulations to me for having
my face all up on Gizmodo now everybody
asked me you really mean to me because
they're jealous they're jealous and they
don't understand my craft they're not
ready for me yet they're not ready for
what I do the world isn't ready yet give
the world a couple more days and then
I'll come back and they'll understand
what I'm trying to do anyway I have good
news there is a new Yahoo site at Green
yahoo.com and among content from really
amazing famous environmentalists NRDC
Amory Lovins tree huggers got some
content on there will changing there is
prime feet
Iko geek content we've been working on
this deal for a long time and I have
been able to talk about it I say some of
you but I couldn't say anything because
it was really secret and I was worried
that it was gonna work out it did work
out but it's running in and up and I'm
getting traffic and it's just really
freaking awesome that I am writing kind
of for Yahoo and they're sending me lots
of Yahoo traffic so that's some super
freaking duper news additionally I of
course have a couple of things to say
about the evil baby orphanage first I
worry a little bit about discussing the
proposal in a public forum for me one of
the biggest thrills of experiencing a
book or a movie or a television show are
the secrets you have to put together the
pieces of the puzzle slowly to build the
picture and and we're going to be
starting in this proposal I think with a
fairly complete picture but I don't want
everybody to see that picture first I
want to hide that picture I'm afraid of
people seeing that picture the
text-based communication thing does make
it harder to do this
but I think we can and just don't know
how so here's a start I'm going to
discuss an issue that I have with this
idea without going in the pond details
the issue there aren't very many evil
baby girls
oh it would be interesting for it to be
a gay evil baby orphanage with lots of
gay evil babies obviously many evil
people in history have been repressed
homosexuals so that could be a direction
that we might go however I don't really
think that I want to go there I want
there to be female characters I want
there to be female leads I want there to
be hot chicks in the evil baby orphanage
we need to figure out where an evil
female baby would come from I mean
obviously that tension could be there
like there might be three boys for every
girl there has to be at least that one
girl so I think we need to know where
the love interests are going to be and
how to include some female evil babies I
will see you tomorrow